Vous voyez les gens qui viennent
obteni
ateliers aussi qui ont lieu tout
au long du week-end : ce qui est
amusant c'est que rmet
de rencontrer des légendes en
personne.
♪
- Au Salon du livre, au détour
d'un kiosque, on peut échanger
la littérature d'ici,
comme Michel Tremblay.
- On a lu ses textes grâce à
notre prof de français et
- C'est vraiment un exemple
à suivre. On l'aime beaucoup.
- Et il explique de sa propre
façon et il montre ce que
la culvraimevraimevraimevraimev.
- Une joie réciproquepour ces js
et ce grand auteur.
MICHEL TREMBLAY, auteur
son lectorat vieillit avec soit
et tout à coup, on se rend
compte qu'il y a des professeurs
qui enseignent encore
ce qu'on fait. Puis on est
ce qui se passe.
- Cette année, le Salon due Sale
se déroule au Palais des congrès
et abrite pas moins de
500 kiosques de s
participeront aux 2500 séances
de dédicaces. Certains,rtains,r,
pour la première fois.
LOUISE DESCHÂTELETS, animatrice,
chroniqueuse et auteure
- Ça, c'est un peu gênant...
pour ma part à moi, pa
C'est à la fois gênant parce que
c'est moi qui m'
parce que ça me représente
et en même temps, ça me permet
d'entrer en contact avec
les ge
- Alors que d'autres sont
des habitués, comme
Tristan Demers, qui a participé
durantlons dans 11 pays.
TRISTAN DEMERS, auteur
- Le salon du livre,
c'est une vitrine. L'objectif
est deet les signer; mais donner
le goût de la lecture avant
tout. Pour moi, c'est ça
la vraie mission d'un salon
- Une étincelle qui peut
s'embraser et se transform
en vocation.
ENZO LORD MARIANO, auteur
depuis que je suis tout petit
pour les dédicac,
c'est à mon tour de faire des
dédicaces aux gens, aux jeunes.
des congrès, des activités sont
offertes toute la fin de sa fine
en ligne et dans la ville,
mais ce 44e Salon du livre
le thème "Se retrouver, enfin."
OLIVIE dg,
Salon du livre de Montréal
- Ça fait 18 mois qu'on est
en pandémie. Ça fait 18 mois
qu'on vit dans notre univers
duellement sans rencontrer
personne; c'est une victoire
de pouvoir être ensemble.
- Une occasion d'échanger
et de célébrer les mots.
Ici Nabi-Alexandre Chartier,
Radio-Canada, M